- And I will be historically correct.
I cannot wait to read your article
in 37 years and say see
this is what I said.
(shouting)
- [Gary] You got your perspective.
(techno music)
I just wanna be happy,
don't you wanna be happy?
(phone ringing)
- [Jack] This is Jack.
- [Gary] Hey it's Gary
Vaynerchuk, how are you?
- [Jack] I'm good Gary, how are you?
- Very good.
- [Jack] Thank you for calling me.
- Thanks for the interest.
- [Jack] So I don't
know how much you've uh
you've been apprised of
the story I'm working on.
- I have a good sense.
- [Jack] So basically
I also weirdly without
knowing of the timing
where we got together
got into a little bit of
twitter conversation last night
so I'm very
I'm aware of what talking about
and I'm a
I've been paying attention very closely
for a very long time.
- [Jack] Oh great!
So yeah that was kind of a
funny timing with that too.
You know
if you were
given
if Mike Trout came into your
office and said you know,
"I want you to make me
a household name.
I want you to make me Twitter famous."
What would you tell him?
- I would start with a series of questions
for about 15 to 20 minutes
because you have to
reverse engineer someone
who's actually busy and famous.
You have to reverse engineer their DNA.
So for example, Mike
could have those ambitions
yet may feel uncomfortable
in being out there
because he may think it's bragging
'cause that's just his DNA.
And I would explain fine
maybe the format that we need
to put you in is a podcast
where you feel more comfortable
'cause your shooting the shit with friends
and that's how were going to
be able to create content.
Some people are super
comfortable running around Earth
taking selfies
and that's where they create content.
Other people, look- look
at myself, I'm busy.
I'm running an actual company that's big.
I don't
Even though I have a huge audience
and have made myself "big"
by having somebody film me at all times
to create content to be distributed
so the first thing that has to happen
is there's a very big DNA trait difference
in all these people.
I would try to figure
out how to create content
in a world where he was
comfortable in doing that
because most people feel
like they don't have the time
or ironically even though
there in the public eye
don't like it for many different reasons:
skeletons in the closet,
not their DNA trait,
they were taught to be
humble by their grandpa
like there's a million reasons why.
But I would ask him a series of questions
that put me in a situation
that allowed me to create content out of
and preferably in video form
which would then feed
written and audio form
in the way that I think about it.
- [Jack] If you could, you
know, sort of walk me through
what personality traits
align with what format.
- I think the more extroverted you are
the more video,
vlogging,
or having actually somebody
follow you around with a camera
which takes a lot of
a lot of internal understanding
to be okay with that
because it could come across
you know like being a charlatan
or you know
its a real personality trait
which I have a lot of empathy.
You know when I started
doing that three years ago
I knew that it was gonna
be like frowned upon
but now it's happening
at scale on YouTube.
In it's most basic form,
extrovert: video and picture
introvert: it's being
recorded behind the scenes
manifesting as audio and written.
- [Jack] How much do you work
with particular individuals
and how much do you work with brand?
- So we work more with brands
at Vayner Media and I do
but with individuals we have a
division called Vayner Talent
where we have 12, 13 clients
that we do this with.
And then as a human being, I'm
spending quite a bit of time
with awfully famous
individuals off the record
in giving them my points of view
on how they could do better
on socials and how they say it
but its far more holistic than that.
It's being a media entity.
- [Jack] When you're working with brands
is there a type of brand
that you see perhaps
aligning with Mike Trout,
you know and his characteristics
as an athlete and a person?
- You know whether it's performance based
'cause he's a super athlete
or back to the point of it
he's so not out there or super extroverted
I'm sure law firms and banks
and insurance companies
and you know
professional service companies would love
to have a clean-faced, clean
record, super athlete, you know
nice boy be the face of their brand.
- [Jack] Especially
the sport like baseball
where you know there's not as
much focus on the individual
as there is in the NBA
where you have someone
whose personality is not obviously outside
it's a heavier lift.
Has that been true in your experience?
- I think that is way
I think you just walked
into the much, much, much bigger problem
at hand for baseball.
- [Jack] Uh huh.
- I don't believe that that
is a product of anything
other than the way Major League Baseball
has handled themselves versus the NBA.
I mean Reggie Jackson
had a candy bar in 1977.
Let's not get confused
what's happening here.
What's happening here is
that Major League Baseball
a decade ago decided to
make short-term economics
by creating BAM, their media group,
so that they can control
all the short-term dollars
at the detriment of being
everywhere where people are
and building up their individuals.
They've suffocated the creativity
in a digital environment
over the last decade.
There's plenty of
personalities in baseball.
The way that the team's
have to do their creative
in social media
and the way that you can't
find any baseball content
on the internet unless
Major League Baseball
is making a piece of that
action through their accounts
has created a culture of suppression
of personal brands.
I mean literally to the point of
a fan of
Kolten Wong
creating content on Instagram
potentially is gonna be taken
down by Major League Baseball.
Steph Curry was built not only
by Steph Curry and by the NBA
Steph Curry was built by
the fans creating content
of Steph Curry in the trenches
where attention actually is.
There was plenty of interest
in Derek Jeter and A-Rod
in real life.
Bryce Harper is loaded with everything
that you'd be interested in.
It's suppressed out of him systematically.
- [Jack] So if you were
commissioner for day,
what would you change
about the League's approach
to digital?
- I would open up the communistic
point of view dramatically
and have far more partnerships
and leeway with the actual audience
and I would disproportionately
be petrified
that six to 13 year olds in America
consider Messi, Ronaldo, LeBron, Curry,
and Ninja the Fortnite
player way more famous
than any single baseball player on Earth.
That is going to play itself out
in an extremely negative
way in a 40 year window
and like every other business on Earth
baseball decided to treat
digital for short-term money
instead long-term IP
and success and brand.
- [Jack] I mean the thing this like
I think about baseball fandom
as oh it gets passed down
you know from father to son
and you root for you
know a particular team
and if that skipped a generation
or if that is skipping a generation
you know is that salvageable?
- It's not.
There gonna take the short-term
There gonna take the short
It's funny how I think about short-term.
I was literally about to say
they take the short-term loss
which is actually a 30 year window.
It's salvageable if they
start now with you know
with fathers and sons,
mothers and daughters
interested in baseball
having the ability to pass it on
in a YouTube, Snapchat, app
you know how they
Baseball said "You're
gonna consume us the way
we baseball want, not the way you want."
And the problem for them is it was great
for the short-term, you know,
and it looked great like
they're making all this money
but what they did was
fundamentally destroyed
the 50 year window of
their sport in a real way.
People are unbelievably naive
how this is gonna play out.
It's an incredible sport to
take the family out for the day.
That's nice.
So is soccer during the same time of year.
Like this is not going to work out
for baseball in a 50 year window
and it starts with do you care.
And I think that the answer
is no I do not believe so.
I couldn't be more down on
baseball 35 years from now
based on what they're doing now.
Kids are not growing up with
baseball cards like they did.
Their attention's in different places.
There's new alternatives
like everyone's like
well it's a great summer
night, well guess what
do you know what every eight
to 13 year old in America
is doing on summer nights right now
they're staying inside
and playing Fortnite.
- [Jack] Yeah.
- So I don't care if you're
good for the outside.
If nobody's going outside you're finished.
And guess what I think
people need a history lesson.
Boxing and horse racing
were the most popular sports
along with baseball in this
country in 1920, 30, and 40
and they were radio sports, that's why.
And then television came along
and football and basketball
were television sports.
And guess what they've benefited.
And guess what, now
we're in a digital world
and that's who's going
to benefit a.k.a E-sports
a.k.a. things like the NBA
that understand how to manipulate it.
And who's going to lose?
Baseball.
You know why,
'cause they make an extra
hundred million dollars
in little pennies and nickels
in ads on their channels
that they rev share with
YouTube or Facebook.
Yet nobodies going there
and it's not cultural
and nobody gives a crap.
And then classic NHL
that's always been bad
decides to sign up with BAM.
I mean talk about a sport
that barely holding on to relevance.
And so what they did--
What they did was literally
go into the same drug
and sign up with BAM media
which is devastating to
me because I adore hockey.
Super hard to get excited about something
if you can't see it.
And I don't wanna hear like
well players have accounts on social.
They sure do, but when the
team's content is sucked
into being controlled by the organization
like it doesn't fester a culture.
The Padres don't have a
culture of creating content
that's really progressive
because it's part of the BAM machine
so they're sucking off the
teat of BAM and there's
and so then all of a sudden
if there's not a culture
inside the organization
well the players don't feel a
natural kinship towards that.
And it's crazy because
baseball is super cultural.
Matt Kemp dated Rihanna.
Like they have nothing
but ammo culturally.
You know what I mean.
- [Jack] No, and I think
they've certainly succeeded in
I mean maybe there's some pushback
but I do think baseball has succeeded
in making it seem like
the player's problem
as opposed to the league's problem.
- So to me that's a really great,
great conversation because anytime
a leader
says their employees are at fault
there in the beginning of
the process of the end.
- [Jack] Yeah.
- The utter lack of
accountability is laughable.
Baseball took the money in
the short-term in digital
and they destroyed the long-term
value of the entire thing
because of it.
The end.
And I will be historically correct.
And I can not wait to read
your article in 37 years
and say, "See, this is what I said."
- [Jack] Do you think
though even in that climate
there's a way for players
to break through
- Yes
- [Jack] Their personalities.
- Yes, I do.
Yes of course I do.
But it is so much more
in the vested interest
of the team's than it is for the players.
The players are there
for three to 12 years.
The teams are trying
to do it in perpetuity.
But what you had was a bunch
of old owners take the cash.
Because when you're owned by 32 people
that are of the ages of 59,
as the youngster, to 92,
you take the short-term economics.
Please understand my energy,
I'm angry at the owners
for not holding up the
sanction of baseball
for the long-term
for their selfish
short-term financial wants.
So yes do I think Aaron
Judge could do anything
and everything?
Of course I do.
But I do think maybe 'cause I am a CEO
and like being a leader
that you need to create the environment
for people to flourish.
And I do not believe baseball
has done that digitally,
contemporarily, or you know the end.
What's, what's baseball doing about it?
What are they doing with all the
where is all that money going?
Aaron Judge makes a lot
of money, a lot, a lot.
And he can hire a social
media person, cool!
The Dodger's make a lot of money.
Where's it going?
- [Jack] Yeah.
Like where is it going?
And so the utter lack of
investment in the long-term IP
of the asset you own only
speaks to my confidence
and my bravado on this subject matter.
And by the way, here's the point of this.
There will be plenty
people that will read this
or watch this that are
going to disagree with me
because you don't see it
happening until it's too late.
- [Jack] Right.
- People are going to
tweet at me and be like,
"Gary, you're an idiot, attendance is up."
Okay (Jack laughs).
Guess what?
Most companies that go out of business
have their best year before
the beginning of the end.
Toys R Us, when I was saying
Toys R Us was out of business,
people shit on me left and right
'cause they pointed to
the numbers of the sales.
I was like that's cute
but you don't understand
that they're not
positioned for the future.
Let's talk real life.
If you're an 86 year old owner and you
and if you're even smart enough
to realize what's happening
and you're saying "but yeah
but I making so much more
economics on the digital rights
and my kids aren't going
to be left with this anyway
because of the way taxes
work and inheritance tax
and so I'm gonna leave this
bag on the next dumb dope."
That's really what's happening.
The 88 year old owner is saying,
"I don't give a fuck about the Angels.
I care about me and I care about my kids
but I'm not going to
leave it to them anyway."
Because they can't pay the inheritance tax
so they're gonna sell it, right?
- [Jack] Yeah.
- And I just don't care
about baseball in 2063.
I genuinely believe
that's what's happening
with the, and listen carefully,
with the most intelligent of owners.
The dopey owners don't even
realize it's happening.
Because they so disrespect
where the attention of
the consumer actually is.
Why did wrestling get big in the '80s?
Because Vince McMahon knew
where the kid's attention was
and if you put wrestling
on Saturday morning
on MTV then people care.
All that the internet is now:
Instagram, Facebook, Snapchat
YouTube, podcasts that is MTV.
- [Jack] I think there are
a lot of baseball writers
whose retort is sort of along the lines of
well if you, if you can't appreciate
what's so great about Mike
Trout then hell with you anyway.
- That's great, that's what everybody says
before they go out of business.
(Jack laughing)
Right, if you don't love my product
well then you're an idiot.
Cool, the market is always right.
I massively appreciate, I'm a,
do you know how big of a boxing fan I am?
Like it's called the sweet science.
It is one of the most fascinating things
for me to watch, right?
Here's the problem.
When it all went pay per view
and nobody could see it on free TV
everybody lost the appreciation
because they didn't see it.
There's a very specific reason
soccer's happened in America
more than it's ever had before.
It's called FIFA the
video game and it's called
English Premier League game's
are actually on television
in the morning on Saturday.
- [Jack] Yeah.
- This is not complicated.
This is what I do for a living.
It's called attention.
And Major League Baseball has
absolutely dropped the ball
over the last decade on attention
and they will feel the ramifications
over the next half century.
(Jack laughing)
- [Jack] We've gotten a little
bit away from Mike Trout.
Don't you agree?
- But, I think
But, I think to your point
I think you can sense it.
It's super important because
it's not about Mike Trout
because then you can absolutely make this
a very narrow argument
about one man's personality.
This is epidemic.
This is how did we get to this moment.
Because I'm sure you agree with me
that you know there are
tons of guys in the league
that have nothing
I mean do you know how much
money I could make Aaron Judge
just on the gap in between
his two front teeth
from a business standpoint?
I just need, but you need
to make that you know
you need to make that culture.
José Altuve is five foot five.
Like everything that
everybody says to why you know
why Steph Curry is so culturally amazing
'cause everybody feels
that they can be him.
José Altuve is a Latino
who's five foot five.
That is unbelievably at
scale in America, right?
- [Jack] Yeah.
- I mean these are ridiculous
conversations, you know,
mechanics, models, like there's
plenty of things to be done.
Javier Báez has more
personality in his left pinky
than most athletes in America.
- [Jack] (laughs) Right.
- Right?
I mean that hasn't even
gotten into the fact
that 38% of these dudes
are strikingly handsome
and if you just take their shirt off
and put it on Instagram lots
of good shit will happen.
(Jack laughing)
- [Jack] The thing is like
and it did cross my mind when I was
when I was conceiving of this story
because I said well okay
so Trout's not famous
but then really like you look
around a game maybe Harper
and Justin Verlander
'cause he dates Kate Upton
- Married.
- [Jack] married Upton,
are famous but I don't really know
you know David Ortiz was famous.
He's retired.
- Yeah.
- [Jack] It's hard to see--
- Yeah and meanwhile
you've got so much, look
when we're having a marketing discussion
not an on the field discussion, right?
One of the best baseball
players in the world
plays in Boston and his name is Mookie.
- [Jack] Yeah.
- Like you know like there's so much,
Scooter Gennett is Scooter!
Nice guy in a nice market.
There's so much to do with him.
I mean look, I really know
baseball, like this is not,
I'm not pontificating from--
- [Jack] No, I know.
If you know Scooter
Gennett, you know baseball.
- I drafted Scooter Gennett two years ago
when he got cut by Brewers
because I knew how good
of a prospect he was.
Like I really know baseball.
I'm not even talking about culturally
but like you give me Manny Machado
forget about getting traded to the Dodgers
and now he's in L.A.
you give him to me in Baltimore
I'll make him a real celebrity.
I've made myself a bigger
celebrity than these guys.
I'm a 42 year old business man.
Let's talk about another thing
back to you know
whether it's Segura or
whether it's you know Baez
or Altuve or Eddie Rosario who's exploding
another guy I drafted
three years ago by the way
for a dollar in my fantasy league.
I mean America has never been more Latin
has never been more Latino, Hispanic,
has never been more
specially at the youth
and baseball is the most
Hispanic, Latino in our country.
This is, they're not putting out content
where people actually live
and that's it.
It's as simple as that.
They don't have a culture of it.
They took the short game
and they will pay the price.
Can I throw another thing
at because I think it adds
to the Mike Trout conversation?
- [Jack] Absolutely.
- 'Cause it
'Cause it uses Bryce Harper
who I think is always
the fun kind of, right
that's the fun conversation
with those two.
- [Jack] Right.
- I mean would you not agree with this.
I believe baseball as platform
has sucked the star power
and charisma out of Bryce Harper
that he naturally came in with.
- [Jack] I, uh, explain,
explain more.
- Sure, let's think about
Bryce Harper's personality
six or seven years ago.
I think people are going to
talk about well he "grew up"
and that's why he's not
acting as a you know--
- [Jack] Yeah, yeah.
- Right, I say not true.
I say he's been suppressed
by the culture of.
- [Jack] I think, I think
that's possible although again
that's something where you don't know
whether that's coming from the league
or from the clubhouses.
- I couldn't agree more.
You could have a 41 year old catcher
that puts a hand on a kid and says,
"Yo kid, shut the fuck up."
Right?
- [Jack] Right, you don't act that way.
- I have a funny feeling
if Major League Baseball had a culture
where a 41 year old
catcher could make $300,000
off the field 'cause he's a personality
that you would see things
change systematically.
- [Jack] Yeah.
- And so I'm with you.
I think I, as you can tell
I'm not naive to this.
This is something I'm
very passionate about
and know a lot of the nuances.
I'm speaking to, its Major League Baseball
as the organizations requirement
to create a culture of
fame
and fun
and contemporary executions
that would then overtime trickle down to.
- [Jack] Mm hmm.
It's so funny because I
was at the game yesterday
in an elevator with Rob Manfred
I wish I had just
I wish I had talked to you before--
(Gary laughing)
- You would have--
- [Jack] Yelled at him.
- I mean look, listen I have
unbelievable amounts of respect
for the point of view.
I just unbelievably disagree.
And
- [Jack] Right.
- And he is the employee of owners
so he runs the company line.
But it is very clear that
they took the short money
and ran with it
and they will be the generation
that made baseball culturally irrelevant.
- [Jack] Well and this is a little bit off
but perhaps relevant, you know,
I remember an old boss of mine
used to kind of make the argument
that the whole steroid
saga was such a mistake
because it resulted in the commissioner
and ownership demonizing the
biggest stars of the game.
And making them into pariahs
and consequently making the you know--
- Baseball in the two
examples that you just said
and it's an interesting thought
and I haven't spent a lot
of time thinking about it
so as you can see I'm passionate
when I've thought a lot
and I get a little more quite
but if, let's say we
agree and I'm gonna let
that marinate for a month
and I'll text you be like you were right.
Let's say we agree, you
know what that speaks to?
Another example when baseball's not taking
on it's responsibility and
throwing it on the player.
Yesterday, it's player's fault
that he's not more famous
I need him to tango with me.
Are you kidding me with the steroid era?
You're absolutely right actually.
It didn't take me very long to marinate.
They through their players under the bus.
I want one common sense
individual to sit down with me
and tell me they didn't
know what was going on.
- [Jack] Right.
- Here's my--
- [Jack] Of course they knew.
- Here's my problem.
Parents love to shit on
millennials without recognizing
they're the ones who created them.
- [Jack] Yeah.
- The utter lack of accountability
against their own stars
is devastating to me.
Baseball's very good at not
taking on accountability.
It's time it does and
they better move quickly
because very quickly people are going
to be watching video game players
throw swords at each other
instead of baseballs
and hitting with bats.
Very quickly.
- [Jack] Yeah.
- As a matter of fact
it's already happened.
Now it's can they start to
process of unwinding it.
Because the days of baseball cards
in you bike spokes are over.
- [Jack] Yeah.
No, I mean it's absolutely true.
And it's just like if they
can't make a generation
of young players
- It's over.
- [Jack] this talented
and this distinctive
- It's over.
- [Jack] Yeah.
- It's over and you know what for them
you know the audacity to
make Mike Trout a part
of the conversation when he's
everything you'd ever want.
Right?
- [Jack] Right.
- Like my great goal in life is Mike Trout
is the kind of guy my daughter marries.
So the fact that they're willing to go
Like have we gotten to
that place where now that's
who they're willing to
subtly through under the bus?
Because don't get it twisted
that's exactly what he did yesterday.
- [Jack] Yeah.
No and like I mean I'm just thinking now,
you know if you've ever
spent any time around like
Francisco Lindor or something
and you know I'd probably talk to the guy
15 minutes total in my life.
But how is that guy not,
you know, among the
- You're preaching.
You're preaching and guess
what it's baseball's job
when fucking LeBron's there
during their World Series run
to get LeBron with Lindor
in a picture and all over social media.
I mean JuJu Smith-Schuster
is doing a better job
hacking culture
than the entire Major
League Baseball machine.
- [Jack] Yeah.
- Where's the money going?
They're not reinvesting in their business.
They're sucking it dry and
they will pay the price.
- [Jack] Yup.
- Period end of story,
period end of story.
Every other conversation is the micro
and is fundamentally
irrelevant to the actual thing
that's happening.
- [Jack] Yeah.
- Cool, I got to go.
- [Jack] Yeah, this was awesome, man.
Thanks so much.
- Thank you, man, take care.
- [Jack] Alright, bye.
- That's a lesson for everybody
in everything in life.